my name is susana agua I'm from aveda
institute for ecological research an
organization that works for the
conservation and sustainability of
Brazil but in fact I think of the planet
one of the questions I am why I'm here
we my husband and I were winners of the
World Economic Forum has the schwab
award for entrepreneur of the year and
mo 2009 my husband and I were privileged
to receive honored with this award I
will be thinking about the unity and
growth of Latin America which was a
question from what clean Edmonds I think
working and listeners one of the things
that Latin American have Latin America
has in common is the environmental of
richness and the biodiversity and
because I'm an environmentalist I think
maybe we could
this aspect of Latin America to unite us
and strengthen our efforts to make this
planet more equitable and more balanced
Latin America has potential with water
with soil with forests with species that
is so outstanding and the rest of the
world right now is an environmental
crisis and I think we should unite
strengthen our efforts and make it
possible for the whole planets to help
us protect what is ours but it has to
begin with us we should promote the
pride and stand for what we have and not
pretend that the rest of the world is
better than we are or try to copy
development model that does not protect
and prioritize the environmental we are
the environment and what happens is the
environment help happens to us so I
think the balance between people and
nature should be this trend of latinum
you